dada la integral definida que va de
menos 1 a 3 de fx de x que es igual a
menos 2 y la integral definida que va de
menos 1 a 3 de gtx de x que es igual a 5
cuál es la integral definida que va de
menos 1 a 3 de 3
fx menos 2 gx de x bueno lo que podemos
hacer es usar algunas propiedades de las
integrales y lo primero que me gustaría
hacer es separar esta expresión en dos
integrales porque sabemos que tanto para
integrales definidas como indefinidas la
integral de fx más o menos g de xx es
igual a la integral de fx de x
más o menos la integral de gd x de x si
esto es más esto será más y si esto es
menos esto será menos así que podemos
separar esta expresión de la misma forma
esto es igual a la integral definida que
va de menos 1 a 3 de 3
fx de x menos la integral definida que
va de menos 1 a 3 de 2 g de x de x y
miren lo único que hice fue separar esto
la integral de la resta de estas dos
funciones es lo mismo que la resta de
las integrales de esas funciones ahora
lo siguiente que podemos hacer es sacar
los escolares de las integrales porque
observen que las funciones se
multiplican por estos números 3 y 2 así
que podemos sacarlos de la integral
porque sabemos que hay una propiedad en
la que si tenemos la integral de una
constante por fx
de x esto es igual a la constante por la
integral de fx de x así que podemos
reescribir esto como vamos a ver la
primera integral nos queda como 3 por la
integral definida que va de menos 1 a 3
de fm x de x menos lo escribiré de otro
color menos 2 por la integral definida
que va de menos 1 a 3 dgt x de x y esto
a que es igual bueno ya sabemos a que es
igual esta parte lo voy a subrayar de
anaranjado bien nos dicen que la
integral definida que va de menos 1 a 3
de fx de x es igual a menos 2 entonces
esto es igual a menos 2 e igualmente nos
dicen que la integral definida que va de
menos 1 a 3 dgt x
de x es igual a 5 esto es igual a 5 por
lo tanto nos queda 3 por menos 2 que es
igual a menos 6 menos 2 por 5 es decir
menos 10 y esto es igual a menos 16 ahí
está